valentina para concretar que el
presidente electo pues asuma su cargo
faltan dos meses y antes de eso hay tres
pasos importantes que el candidato a
presidente elector yo bailé tiene pues
que cumplir primero es el 14 de
diciembre en esta fecha los delegados
electorales ya definidos en cada estado
después de que finalice el conteo los
líos legales y los re conteos en el caso
de georgia por ejemplo pues los
delegados electorales esa fecha votaran
depositarán su voto a el candidato yo
bailén para pasar y ajustar los 270
votos electorales necesarios para
confirmar ya al presidente de eeuu la
segunda fecha importante que hay que
tener en cuenta es el 6 de enero esa
fecha el congreso de eeuu el legislativo
confirma a joe biden como presidente de
eeuu y obviamente el 20 de enero que es
la confirmación la posición de joe biden
acá en washington como nuevo presidente
eeuu el presidente número 46 cristóbal
algo que en este momento tenemos y que
sabemos todos es que aún nos quedan
algunos meses con el presidente de trump
en el poder sabemos que es una persona
que en muchos momentos ha reaccionado de
manera explosiva y que ya en este
instante ha hablado de fraude sin
fundamentos qué va a pasar con el
mandatario
sí pues habíamos visto que él estaba en
un club de golf cuando se entera de la
noticia regresará obviamente a la casa
blanca desde allá se espera en las
próximas horas un comunicado de parte de
su campaña de parte de él todo el mundo
tiene mucha expectativa sobre lo que
pueda decir su reacción en las redes
sociales pero le quiero mencionar
también valentina lo que los americanos
estadounidenses pueden esperarse una vez
pues yo bailé llegue a la presidencia
obviamente el tono en sus relaciones
internacionales de ahora en adelante una
vez se posesiones yo bailen va a cambiar
sobre todo por ejemplo como ya lo
habíamos informado en relación al
acuerdo climático de parís eeuu volvería
a ser parte de este acuerdo climático la
relación con china sería en un tono
seguramente mucho más pues familiar
mucho más de mucha más cercanía y en lo
que tiene que ver con bruselas con la
otan también habría mucha más cercanía
de parte de un gobierno de joe biden con
la otan en lo que tiene que ver con
cambio climático
lo dijo también la campaña de joe biden
abrirá en la casa blanca una oficina
específica para el cambio climático para
tratar los retos del cambio climático y
que como lo dijo joe biden pues promover
y crear la cantidad de empleos que
quiere crear empleos verdes que como lo
dijo en campaña va a ser uno de sus
enfoques durante los próximos cuatro
años de presidencia y obviamente como lo
dijo recientemente en su comunicado su
rol principal su papel principal va a
ser unir al país curar estas heridas de
división este discurso de antagonismo
que viene escuchándose en los últimos
años esa va a ser una de las misiones
principales de iovine en los próximos
cuatro años
cristóbal sabemos que el candidato
demócrata ya electo presidente de eeuu
había hablado que ya se estaba reuniendo
junto con su fórmula vicepresidencial y
un grupo de expertos para tratar esta
pandemia de ccoo y 19 que cada vez
golpea más fuerte a eeuu pero qué otras
medidas se esperan de byd en una vez que
se ha elegido presidente
exacto con el tema de la pandemia es un
tema muy importante que yo voy dénia
kamala harris su fórmula
vicepresidencial le importan mucho le
importan sobre todo valentina porque ya
se han reportado casos diarios de
100.000 estadounidenses contagiados al
día la cifra de muertos en eeuu supera
las 230 mil muertes en este país
entonces el mensaje de joe biden para
cuando llegue a la presidencia después
del 20 de enero cuando se confirme va a
ser lo que ha repetido en campaña es
escuchar a los científicos escuchar a
fauci escuchar a la cdc escuchar a la
cantidad de otros organismos de sanidad
que se han pronunciado y han pedido por
ejemplo medidas como la de el porte de
tapabocas obligatorio el presidente de
trump a duras penas empezó a ponerse el
tapabocas semanas antes de que él mismo
fuera contagiado entonces él pues ahora
presidente electo viene con una política
mucho más estricta de pues cuidar a sus
ciudadanos estadounidenses con respecto
a él
kobe y esto lo ha repetido ya bailén
varias veces no quiere decir que va a
interferir en el desarrollo económico al
menos en que la economía de eeuu sigue a
flote yo vaivén dice que pues los
restaurantes por ejemplo tienen que
empezar a crear las divisiones entre
mesas tiene que representar de cuidarse
mucho más el distanciamiento social para
que en eeuu se reduzca esta cifra de
contagios que es una de las más altas en
el mundo
cristóbal y me devuelvo un segundo algo
que ustedes estaba explicando hace un
momento y es que una de las de los
periodos clave se llama puerto seguro
después de que las agencias le han dado
esta victoria al candidato pues todavía
faltan estos puntos de los de los que
usted nos habló y este puerto seguro es
un periodo en el que se solucionan
litigios electorales en el que hay
resolución de recursos de trump por lo
que muchas personas dicen que a un
vaivén no puede respirar tranquilo que
que se espera que el recurso se espera
que presente el mandatario más allá de
lo que su campaña ya ha hecho que ha
pedido un reconteo de votos y pues que
que ha dicho que hay un notorio fraude
electoral y todo esto ha sido sin
fundamentos las autoridades electorales
de eeuu lo han calificado de ofensivo
si de hecho el presidente trantrán tanto
en su cuenta de 'twitter' como por otros
canales ha dejado claro que él tiene
muchas pruebas muchas pruebas de fraude
por ejemplo como publicó un vídeo anoche
sobre un supuesto fraude en michigan y
fraude también en pensilvania donde la
cuenta de su cuenta de twitter de hecho
ha sido pues no bloqueada pero ha sido
le han puesto avisos a sus mensajes en
twitter sobre información imprecisa
sobre información sacada de contexto que
puede llevar pues a crear noticias
falsas sobre eso esas acusaciones que
hace él sobre un supuesto fraude en las
elecciones lo que ya ha dicho don ottón
que va a hacer es demandar esto está de
imponer y poner demandas ha sido una
práctica constante del presidente trompo
no solamente en su vida empresarial sino
también durante esos cuatro años de
administración y lo que piensa hacer es
como lo ha revelado también su jefe de
campaña es demandar las autoridades
electorales de los estados que
recientemente pues eran de mayoría en
los votos
y favorecían al candidato republicano
donald trump pero que recientemente
incluso hoy pues como lo vimos en el
caso de pensilvania terminaron
favoreciendo y dándole la presidencia a
yo bailé en esos cuatro estados en
nevada en arizona en pensilvania y en
georgia pues el presidente tram tiene
una estrategia va a ser la de demandar
las autoridades electorales allá para
que haya reconteo y para que sobre todo
el voto por correo y el voto anticipado
se cuente mejor el presidente trump dice
que hay muchos votos militares que se
han contado mal y que esos votos podrían
revertir le por ejemplo la situación en
georgia o en arizona
cristóbal por último le preguntó por
kamala harris porque somos muchos los
que estamos diciendo que esta mujer está
haciendo historia en este momento se
está convirtiendo en la primera mujer
vicepresidenta de eeuu y la primera afro
la primera mujer con ascendencia
afroamericana que podemos decir de ella
que podemos esperar sabemos que se ha
mostrado muy emocionada en redes
sociales que su familia también ha
reaccionado
en redes sociales de mostrándole todo su
apoyo
es importante lo de kamala harris además
es una mujer que pues es del comunas y
ella así es como se pinta así es como se
vende ella ella además pues se educó
parte de su educación secundaria fue en
canadá ha vivido en varias ciudades de
eeuu después se estableció en california
donde fue fiscal allá y pues el libro
luchas muy importantes como fiscal sobre
todo en el tema de el monopolio de
muchas empresas en cómo muchas empresas
acá le sacan provecho por ejemplo a el
tema del lobby y cómo siguen avanzando
para ir ganando más y más y más pues
espacio en el mercado apropiándose
creando oligopolios ese fue una de las
cartas que kamala harris se jugó con el
hijo de joe biden para quitarle esa ese
poder grande que tienen las grandes
corporaciones en estados unidos
queriendo luchar por una competencia
justa en el mercado ella ha defendido
mucho esa carta a la carta de queremos
que el capitalismo funciona pero
funcione para todos que sea inclusivo
las pequeñas como las empresas que pues
ella ha defendido puedan salir adelante
y no sean opacadas por los grandes
pulpos financieros en este país yo creo
que eso es lo que se puede esperar acá
en eeuu los estadounidenses pueden tener
seguro que ella va a seguir su lucha
para que el capitalismo funcione para
muchos y no para unos pocos como lo
criticaba ella cuando una fiscal en
california